We'll now put together everything that you've learned in this lesson, to solve
an important problem, how to validate the input that a human user provided.
Think again about the program with which we started this lesson, the elevator
simulator. The user enters a number between one and 18, but not 13. There is no
button labeled 13. And then that program computed the actual floor. Never mind
that part. What I want to talk about is the part where we read the user input.
In a program we don't have buttons. But we ask the user to type in the input.
There's a prompt. And then what if some crazy user now enters 19 in the hope of
getting to the roof or something. Or minus 2. Or some text, users do all sorts
of interesting things. And when they do, the program might misbehave. So it's a
better idea to catch those first, and just tell the user that, that was not
right. Let's list the things that can go wrong and how one can address them in
Java. First off, there's no button 13. And so in Java, you might write, if the
floor equals 13, then print an error for the user. Let's continue. The next
rule is that the bottom floor is one, and the top floor is 18. So if the user
enters a number that is less than one, or greater than 18. We want to reject
that. Here is the Java code. Note the use of the or operator here. If the floor
is less than one, or greater than 18, then we print this error message. And
finally, there is the issue. What if the user doesn't even type any number, but
some words? That would actually be bad. Because, then, the nextInt method would
fail. Let me show you how to protect against that. There is another method that
we haven't yet seen, called hasNextInt, which looks at the user input, and,
instead of, doing what the nextInt method does, namely returning it It just
checks whether it is an integer or not. It returns true, if the user entered an
integer. It returns false, if the user entered something else. In other words,
it's a method that returns a Boolean value. So we can test for that, in the if
statement. If the method returns true, then it is safe to call nextInt. We can
read the input, and then process it in any way we want. If on the other hand
this method returns false, then we print an error message. Now, it's your turn.
Put those three pieces together, and fix up the elevator demo so that any bad
input from the user is caught and the program only proceeds when the user did
the right thing. An integer between 1 and 18, but not 13.